if we go right back to the start
i had a vision i had an idea and i was
so passionate about it i just want jim
sharp to be a truly iconic great brand a
leader in culture and helps inspire
people around the world
that was a period of great
self-reflection for me what am i bad at
what am i good at and i decided to lean
into my strengths in the early days i'd
have gone i'm introverted shy you know
and i'm not good at people management
but i didn't want to identify with those
things you should be able to look at
those things and try and solve them
everything came crashing down around me
because because there was nowhere to
hide like that definitely hit me and it
definitely hurt me and i really felt
like i was carrying that burden
honestly just keep trying and keep
trying and don't be afraid to fail i
think that's so so so important i've
never met anyone
who was genuinely successful that wasn't
hard working
[Music]
ben francis
the guest that you requested again and
again and again he is the founder and
now the ceo of gymshark the global gym
brand worth billions and billions and
billions that started right here in the
uk
founded by ben who was in his early 20s
and who is still in his 20s now as he's
leading the global brand all around the
world with 900 employees
this is a conversation i have honestly
looked forward to for a long long time
because there is nobody else in the uk
like ben that has built such an iconic
company that you see everywhere that has
maintained its integrity while they're
still in their 20s
ben's net worth is probably
pretty close to or over a billion
dollars and remarkably
he's one of the most humble individuals
one of the most introspective self-aware
people i have ever met a really good guy
and if you're someone that someday might
want to follow in his footsteps or you
want to build a business or just pursue
the thing that matters to you the most
then this is the conversation for you
i can't wait for you to hear this
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
ben
when i look back on my life i only in
hindsight have managed to start piecing
together some pieces that have
enlightened me to
why i became the person i went on to
become and why i had the interests and
skills and all those things and also
like the insecurities um when i look at
your early years back in bromsgrove at
school i started to like connect a few
dots but i wanted to know in your own
sort of self-assessment whether you
you can now see any patterns from your
early years that you would consider an
anomaly
that caused you to become the anomaly
you are today
um
so
so i i think i had two
sort of really lucky moments so the
first one was at about 14 years old i
think it's about 14. you know when you
do work experience yeah so everyone just
sort of work experience at school
um and the work experience that i did at
that age was basically with my granddad
and what my granddad would do is he
would travel around the midlands um and
he would lie in furnaces so furnaces big
ovens basically where you would stick
airplane parts in it would heat them up
loosely speaking
and then what he would do was go around
and fill them with either ceramic fiber
or brick so i basically did work
experience with him did a bit of
labouring
and i would be sort of on the sort of uh
cement mix of the drum and i would
basically pass him cement or um he would
teach me to like push in uh ceramic
fiber or labrix or whatever
now it wasn't actually the work that was
important as such other than the fact
that it did teach me hard work but it
was more the fact that they were they
were long days and through those days we
would have conversations that like to be
honest in hindsight probably not too
many younger kids would have been
exposed to um because it was it was all
about like the risk that he took in the
business and the intricacies and so on
he would just talk to me about that and
i'd ask him questions and stuff and
that there was one particular job that
he did that he told me about and it was
it was building a furnace to be shipped
off to germany
and
he'd basically risked pretty much
everything he had on this one particular
job
and he told me about all the worries the
concerns the you know the worries that
he had in terms of you know keeping you
know the house for my nan my mom her
sister
um
and at the time it didn't really i don't
to me it was just a story that my
granddad was telling me
but then as i grew up and then i started
taking business risks of my own i do
remember thinking oh yeah but my risks
are nothing compared to his so i think
that certainly helped and like i said
just learning that hard work i think
watching my mom's worked in the nhs my
entire life she was incredibly
incredibly hard working i also got
fortunate at school because i did so i
did my gcses
and i wasn't i didn't do particularly
well i was sort of like a d is student
sort of like pretty average
i ended up getting into sixth form i was
super lucky and one of the classes that
i took then was a b tech and i t and
that i don't know if you remember the b
text you had a levels or b text i'm not
sure if it's still like that in the day
and loosely speaking then a levels were
you'd study you do an exam and b techs
were course work or practical work
to do it or tech in a practical way from
for a btec for me was amazing and that
was a huge moment because through that
btec i learned how to use photoshop
dreamweaver illustrator all of the
like the nuts and bolts that actually i
ended up using to build gymshark so
the combination of learning those bits
of software alongside the fact that
watching my grandparents and my parents
work incredibly hard the risks that my
granddad took to build his business all
of those things i think certainly helped
me when it came to starting up the
businesses that i started what does that
say to you about the type of learner you
are though that it was the practically
practical yeah yeah and that's been
evident even today right because i
remember you saying in a conversation
you had that um
one of the real privileges of your job
is you get to go and learn from the
experts in your inside of your business
so
jim sharp was started in 2012
and for the first few years it was sort
of like i mean it was me and a bunch of
mates basically and my brother came on
and we sort of started to build the
business and everything revolved in many
ways around around myself
and then as the business started to grow
it became
clear to me there was a genuine
opportunity right and listen we were
doing well we could do decent revenues
and so on but there's a difference
between
doing well and doing i don't know a few
thousand pounds in revenue to oh wow
this this could go into the hundreds of
thousands or the millions and
as the business grew
i then started to realize that i needed
to surround myself with great people um
so that that really helped and i think i
got lucky at the start as well because
the people that i then surrounded myself
with helped the business grow so i was
sort of positively reinforced as well
from an early age doing that where did
those people where do those people come
from i've always wondered this because
you
yeah last time we spoke and in
subsequent interviews you've always
cited those people like steven who was
the ceo of jim shark
and others as being really really
instrumental and they almost felt like
they were like
mentors yes they were yeah so
how did you join them so
i'll tell you what happened right so
and this is this is interesting as well
so maybe i don't think this is probably
spoken about enough
as an entrepreneur particularly of a
growing business you'll know this as
well as me
not only do you have to wear loads of
different hats on on a daily basis
but people don't talk enough about the
fact that during the growth of the
business you have to completely change
who you are as a person
not only because
you're developing and you're trying to
improve but because
the business is a separate entity from
yourself and the business requires
different things of its founder or chief
exec depending on the size of the
business so in the early days
and
i don't know how to put this in the
nicest way possible but i think i was a
bit arrogant right it was a bit like
this is my baby i know where i want to
take it and i'm going to drag it there
and i don't i don't really care what you
say
because this is my vision
and that worked to a point right i had i
had a vision i had an idea and i was so
and i still am so passionate about it
and then all of a sudden
i don't know how this happened i think
it was just it naturally happened
through just asking questions i've
always been quite inquisitive then sort
of you start surrounding yourself with
you know with great people and um i
would i would go to the gym right and i
would find like a guy called paul who's
like the business guy and i go and ask
him questions and stuff and all of a
sudden when you surround yourself with
those people you realize this whole
thing of i don't care what you say i'm
going to do what i want anyway that
doesn't work or it works for a period
and then they disappear so then i
realized that i then can't be arrogant
single-minded moving where i want to go
i need to retain a bit of that right but
what i need to do is one learn to work
with people and more importantly learn
to work with great people so that
happened and i met paul at the gym
um and that was just for asking
questions paul introduced me to steve
because steve had previously worked at
reebok um and that sort of fitness
sports where sort of thing um made sense
i ended up meeting a guy called niren
who
worked in uh like a local company and
funnily enough actually on that oh um
i hadn't so i'd met anyone when i was a
kid i don't know i was like
13 14 years old or something and then we
just sort of never kept in touch we went
to uni and whatever
and there was a point where i was really
struggling with something i can't
remember what it was it was something to
do with like selling things online and i
knew that he worked in another
e-commerce company so i sort of messaged
him i think was on facebook at the time
high near and long time no speech you
might have picked your brain on a new on
a few things
he ended up coming in advising us
greatly and then he ended up joining the
business so i think
looking back i think
one i think i managed to learn the
ability to really sell the vision of jim
shark
but secondly i think
the single thing was just asking
questions like i would always just ask
questions of anyone whether they're in
the gym and i know there's people right
there in the gym that i've asked
questions too that probably rolled their
eyes and thought oh god here he is again
but i just want to get on with my
workout but i was i was that person just
asking questions i think that's really
unappreciated about you it's because
because when i was looking through as i
was saying like when i was doing the
research and you're trying to find these
threads throughout your story this one
thread kept coming up in my mind which
was like ben is really like an
insatiable learner he's always trying to
learn even in that you did the
conversation with uh jake humphries on a
high performance
and
at the end of it when he asks you know
you know about the worst things about
your role you basically flip it and say
i'm like the luckiest person on earth
because i get to learn from the best
people in the world a lot of people like
if we think about the impact that being
like a really keen learner has on
someone over 10 years
it's just like an unfair advantage if
you and then i i reflect on the
world of warcraft thing as well and i'm
like connecting these dots i'm like a
lot of people don't get obsessive about
world of warcraft where you're building
and you're learning and you're competing
tell me about this world of warcraft
thing because i only saw a couple of
lines how old i was then i was at school
i just listened i just loved it i
thought it was great i loved so the
three games i loved i loved world of
warcraft i loved call of duty modern
warfare and um gears of war and those
are like the games world of warcraft was
the one that i think i played for the
longest period and the thing i loved
about it was
it was open world for one it had like
its own economy in it so you could like
learn a trade and like you know do
things sell things on the auction house
but you were working with people from
all you were playing with people from
all over the world you had to learn sort
of teamwork
the other thing that was cool about it
was
there wasn't really one so you had like
different like classes of character
right so one was like a like a warlock
and one was like a warrior one was like
strong i had loads of health and could
protect one would inflict loads of
damage on the enemy
the thing there was with teams was there
wasn't one person or one individual that
could do everything there was it was the
group that could do everything but you
needed like all these different like
facets it's like the avengers right the
avengers assemble into this great group
individually they're not as strong and
again all these lessons i think
definitely helped because even when we
talk about today jim sharp sort of
leadership team that's the exact analogy
we use avengers assemble like i don't i
don't want a you know a chief of product
who is the most
wildly intelligent financier or whatever
or commercial person but knows brand
like it's useful that they have an
understanding and respect of those
things
but we want a chief of product who's
really good at cheap of product right
and then we want a chief of brand who's
really good at brand and a chief of
finance who's incredibly good at finance
and then all those people come together
to create a team do you notice that like
at the start of the company like you're
talking about the requirement of
specialists there at the start of the
company
was that very different at the start no
to the start if we go right back to the
start it is literally a case of we need
a group of ambitious individuals that
truly believe in the vision and will
essentially do what it takes to achieve
that
and
there are
so many corners that are cut along the
way because you just have to do what you
can to sort of get by and i think the
other thing as well as in the early days
more often than not
especially if you're sort of they call
it bootstrapping isn't it when you're
not sort of borrowing money as such
you you need to find a way around it
like if you have
50 quid to do advertising you work out
how to advertise with 50 quid there's no
like oh never mind let's go home you
just you have to have great problem
solvers in the business at that stage
um
and to be honest the one of the things
that
as we move through the sort of nine year
history of jim shark
one of the things that i'm what i'm
proud of myself for doing is being able
to adapt from that point of view but
some of the most difficult times have
been that
inevitably there are some people who
can't maybe make that switch from what
was
to the future so that's an incredibly
difficult thing to manage as well and
that's the sort of thing that like you
know what you don't go to business
school or whatever and get and get
taught how to understand
where the level of an individual is or
how to have a certain conversation or
how to be self-aware enough to know what
you sh i shouldn't shouldn't be doing
yeah or where my level is so
yeah there's a hell of a lot of
challenges along the way i can agree
more i always say i've said this on this
podcast before but i ended up hiring
like just really ambitious people that
would like sleep on the floor with me
that had no experience and then
obviously as the business scales and as
you
said there like the the challenges of
the business become different and you
really are looking for experienced
specialists especially to lead the key
departments and uh
i remember that challenge in like year
three of now looking at the people that
have been so loyal to me and thinking i
don't know where you fit yeah anymore
because we need you know and it's
heartbreaking but that's where
you need self-awareness in both camps
where you can sort of have the
conversation that says
like our relationship is our
relationship and i love you to bits
however i need to take a step back and i
need to build this business in a way
that's best for everyone that is going
to help grow it so those are the sorts
of things that i think you can never
truly be prepared for and it's always
hard um
and yeah it was difficult i started
social team with a co-founder you did
too as well from what i understand lewis
yeah um there's very little written
about why why he's no longer with you
i'm guessing i'm guessing from what i've
read that there was just a
difference in opinion about the future
and you decided to go your separate ways
yeah and i think to be fair i think
lewis was lewis was great right in the
early days we would we were literally
inseparable and i think there came a
point where
you're right i had my vision and i think
he had his vision and i just want to be
clear he's like i don't think one is
better than the other it was just a
difference of opinion and to be fair to
him he had so many other interests in
terms of investment and property and all
these different things so lewis
essentially left in
[Music]
i'm gonna say 2014. i could be wrong
maybe 2015. the business was found in
2012 i think he left the business in
2015
um and then he basically retained
20 of his shareholding and then in the
deal that was last year he then sold out
the rest of that and now he's uh
investing and doing other things and
were you friends before
we yeah we were yeah well so we met in
that it class that i spoke about so we
met in it when we were
16 17 whatever the first year of sort of
post school is college sussex form we
met then and then we just went to the
gym together and then there was a group
of like six seven eight of us that would
all go to the gym sort of every day
together and had you decided who did
what so were you the ceo and are you
both ceos was it just no
that so in the early days that never
really happened it was just a bit like
it was a bit like right this is a list
of things that we need to do let's just
tackle them as we go there was no
organization in those days and i think
as the business then got more organized
that's when i think that's when
our vision started to maybe move in
separate directions could that have been
why then because there wasn't clear like
structure at the start that could well
have been to be fair yeah because that's
what you need right you need clear roles
and responsibilities um
and listen regardless if you don't have
that it just it just muddies the water
doesn't it what do you think of of
having the importance of having a
co-founder in the role it plays in those
early stages
in the early stages i think
listen i think it's important i don't
know the stats on how many businesses do
founded by individuals and not i know i
know when lewis left in 2014 2015
the the six months after that was
difficult not too bad it's not in terms
of
the fact that he wasn't doing x y and z
it was just more the fact that like it's
just different isn't it and it's this
whole new world and it's a bit like like
i then naturally well i i then naturally
sort of i didn't lean into this as such
until later on sort of 2018-ish
i then very much became the face of the
business in many ways and then it was
like if people wanted to talk talk about
the business or to the business then
they were coming to myself so
um
yeah i definitely noticed that and um
listen and then i chose to obviously
start pushing that on youtube and stuff
and then that happened more and more
going forward
so talk to me about that so first time
we met i it was actually on a different
series i was running at the time called
like everyday entrepreneurs or something
and when i met you at jim shark's office
i did notice that you were very nervous
very different from home that was about
2015 wasn't it that was in the early
days yeah so hopefully you can see the
change that's happened in me from then
yeah 20 times differently and that so
that was the period that was a period of
great self-reflection for me and that
was when i was literally going right
what am i bad at what am i good at and
what's my choice so
actually around that point i'd split the
two out good bad and i decided to lean
into my strengths i did that for
about three or four years and then i was
like right now i'm really comfortable
with my strengths i know what i'm good
at now i'm going to lean into my
weaknesses and i'm going to become good
at public speaking i don't know people
management all these other things so the
yeah when we met
i was definitely a lot more nervous um
i i it's so fun because i i literally
remember meeting you and i obviously had
this this idea of meeting you this young
guy has made this killer business
whatever whatever whatever i was my
anticipation was that you were going to
be like
loud and like really whatever and you
were so quiet and i could tell you when
you were nervous about the conversation
um
and i would never have guessed that
you're totally different now yeah and
which i think is incredible because it's
just like two for me it's like very very
different people and it's a testament to
your growth yeah but i was i was really
really surprised and i want to share
that because
um it i think there is a lot of people
listening young entrepreneurs or people
that want to that think you know how you
are now is how you will be and there's
no there's no development or
no and this is the thing where i think
what what you need to do again even more
i think i think everyone should do this
whatever field of work they're in or
whatever but particularly as an
entrepreneur because i feel like as an
entrepreneur everything's just amplified
right your your wins are bigger your
losses are larger again um your
weaknesses are you know are exposed
because you are exposed to the business
and the world in many respects
but what you need to do is you need to
write down like your character traits
the best example would be and this is
one that i'm currently working on right
is people would be like
i thought i'm messy or i'm always like
oh i'm always late i'm messy what am i
like and it's a the conversation for me
is a bit like okay you're messing you're
always late but those things should be
up for grabs right you should be able to
look at those things and go don't roll
your eyes and say that's just me because
it's not or it doesn't have to be
because if i'd have done that in the
early days i'd have gone i'm introverted
shy not good in front of cameras
terrible at public speaking and i'm not
good at people management
but i didn't want to identify with those
things i didn't want to say ben is that
because i didn't want to be that and i
think everyone if you can somehow i i
don't i think i was lucky because i was
surrounded by great people right
so
it's definitely easier said than done
but if you can try and not identify with
those things those parts of yourself
that aren't maybe ideal
and you can again look at them in a
logical manner as you would any other
problem in life and try and solve them
so i'm not good at people management
fine who's the best person i know that
is i'm going to go and chat to them i'm
going to pick their brains or even
better i'm just gonna watch them
because some people learn from just
watching some people learn just by
watching and so steve for example who's
the who was the ceo at jim sharp
previously
we didn't have that many
steve teach me how to people manage
steve teach me how to public speak like
we didn't really do that but by him
doing it i just watched him and i
understood the traits or the things that
he would do
that helped him be great at that and
then i just basically learned them and
tried them and tried them and tried them
and eventually got
reasonably good at doing those things
one of the things linked to that that i
always say is um there's no
self-development without self-awareness
and like i i still to this day i've
spoken to a lot of people on this
podcast i have no idea how you make
someone genuinely self-aware and when i
was and when you're talking there about
sitting down and writing a list of my
goods and bads
how do we know that our own like
delusion and our ego isn't writing that
list on our behalf i mean you could ask
someone else to do it the the first
really the time it hit home for me and
it was like a
ton of bricks on the top of my head was
i did a 360 feedback so anyone that
doesn't know what a 360 feedback is you
this i could i'm sure you can find it
online if you google it but basically
you ask the people around you to
describe you and it like prompts you as
it goes so ben is i don't know x y and z
those people fill it in anonymously then
it comes back to you and you have this
like thick bot of paper that basically
fully describes yourself
and i actually did this in it was around
when we met so around 2015 and i had it
and i printed it off and i read it and i
was so
upset and annoyed and i remember
thinking this is not me
and i took it home that night and i it
was just um erratic hot-headed arrogant
um poor manager all these things from
your employees yeah
and it's one of them like the so the
first thing and completely natural is
who said that i'm gonna find him right
that's the first thing now fortunately
it's anonymous you can't do that and
that would be terrible anyway but then i
read it i took it home
um left it on the side and i think i
don't know what i've done i've gone to
the gym or whatever else now my other
half who's now my wife ended up reading
it and i'd come home and i'd seen her
literally just finishing it on like the
last couple of pages and i was so angry
right i literally grabbed it off and i
said mine don't read it like it's not
even me anyway is it like left her alone
and we carried on with that day and then
like later on she was i said um i said
the same i said
that was a load of rubbish wasn't it
that's nothing like me
and then she said
she said that's the most
you
thing i have ever read and then it was
like that was it it was like i i didn't
even say anything i just i remember like
everything came crashing down around me
because because there was nowhere to
hide like she knows me more than anyone
and like i can kick and i can scream and
i can say no it's not true but in my
heart of hearts i knew it was true and
that was the moment i realized i have to
change i have to improve i have to
develop and if you're talking about
becoming self-aware
i think that was my moment
so incredibly true how our partners know
us yeah
and they they can be the most hurtful
but as you said completely accurately
said they're like my girlfriend said
something to me i might on the surface
be like oh yeah but then i go back to my
room and i'm like oh my god like
once your egos had like a couple of
seconds to chill so
you get this list of feedback i remember
doing the 360 thing with my team as well
um and i remember the same feeling like
who the [ __ ] said that like and trying
to work it out like looking over looking
at everybody like i know it was you yeah
it's my assistant um so you get that
list of things back and you can see
areas where you need to improve and you
agree you say okay right i'm going to
start listening what happens like how do
you go about improving on those things
because a lot of them are so like deeply
ingrained in you from
decades of your childhood or whatever
and
especially when you're a winner when
you've been successful in
one thing it validates you it almost
appears to be like validation of
everything so what do you do then what
do you do next yeah you're right so
that's the dangerous thing and i think
that's why i was so fortunate because
jim shark for the most part not entirely
had been very successful until that
point so it was difficult for me to go
well wait a minute i can't be that bad
right but yeah i think the the thing
with robin where she literally put it on
me that that was the moment um so what i
did then and i was actually watching it
was a garyvee video that i was watching
actually so what i did
was i had
the weaknesses which
were both self-defined but defined by
other people
i also have my strengths because by the
way that com your strengths come back
with a 316. no one reads them you only
look at the weaknesses right but there
is a list of strengths in there
somewhere
um and i realized that my strengths
particularly at the time were
around creativity around product around
brand around marketing around
understanding the industry the customer
and so on
so i was you know i was mulling the idea
do i work on my weaknesses do i focus on
my strengths
and to be honest i don't really know the
answer to what the best way of doing
this is but i decided through i think it
was a gary video to focus on my
strengths and i said right you know what
i'm going to do i'm 20 whatever it is 3
24.
i'm
purely going to focus on my strengths
now and that's when i went into a brand
role a product role a marketing role
everything that was front end and
creative at gymshark i completely lent
into that was when steve came into the
business steve became the ceo so i was
sort of like the responsibility of maybe
some of the week the areas i was weaker
at finance ops management that was then
like moved away from me and i purely
completely innocently focused on that
that was your decision yeah it's a
pretty amazing decision
it was heartbreaking as well because
again it's one thing moving yourself out
of a role it's another thing moving
someone then into that role who does it
really good um and like i'm looking at
them i'm like you're way better than me
and i just have to like know that
and make honestly i think i use that as
motivation to one day be as good as that
that was the that was the inspiration i
think maybe because
i was young i knew i had time and i
think that helped um but it was
heartbreaking because the other thing as
well is that doesn't mean to say
exclusively everything steve did for
example i thought was right it just
there was things that he did well i
thought
maybe i wouldn't do that or i would
think differently and sometimes he would
be right and sometimes he would be wrong
but
what i can't do and this is the weird
balance right because i'm founder
and i am like a majority shareholder of
the business so ultimately i have
control of the business
there's no point in me putting him a ceo
and then just overall in what he says
he's in the ceo because he's the best
person for the job and i have to trust
his judgment and opinion and
and it's that weird balance of that and
i never and i never have to this day
played what we'd call like the
shareholder card i've never come in and
gone
this is the way it's going to be just
because
so yeah then i was fortunate enough to
watch steve learn from steve and and
that really helped him
and this was the beginning i think of
the period where i was sort of becoming
a ceo because
i i started off as the chief of brand
right so the business was smaller at
this stage i can't remember the the
exact size or say 20 30 million in
revenue maybe
and i managed the creative the imagery
the videography the
athletes and sponsorships and all these
different things the events
and that was cool because i just
i got a real detailed understanding of
all those things like really detailed i
was in the nuts and bolts of everything
um funnily enough it then happened again
a guy called noel came in who was way
better than me
and he came in as the chief of brand so
again i'm sort of left a little bit high
and dry i was ceo now i'm not chief of
brand now i'm not um you brought him in
as well yeah so he actually came in and
reported into me but it was clear within
uh i don't know a year or so that he was
better so
i vacate the seat he comes in and he's
done a great job since
then i think after that i did i think it
was product for a little bit
which was great fun oh sorry i did
marketing which was great for the
marketing is all that's what it says in
the tin right all the marketing all the
ads you see online everything that comes
with that and that was great fun and i
learned a lot there i traveled the world
i spent time with facebook google's all
the partners like that and i learned a
hell of a lot there did you feel a bit
lost at this point
um because having gone from ceo to brand
to marketing typically when an employee
in my company does that i i tend to get
the impression that they kind of know
that me being moved around a little bit
like a chess piece and it's like they
don't feel like they ever fully own
something or that yeah so i've had that
but i've had i had that for five or six
years because then then it was it was
brand into marketing into product there
was tech for a little bit um
i've moved around a lot so this this
ceo role
is it's the first genuine home i've
found since sort of running the business
back in 2013 2014 and and why why why
did you so you've recently announced
that you're now the ceo i think it's
been roughly about four months yeah
since you uh
you kicked steve out and
evaded
evaded the office and slammed the
shareholder card on his desk and told
him to do one i'm joking um but
since you've sort of regained your
position and
made the decision with steve
um that you wanted to do the role again
yeah what was the thinking behind that
because a lot of founders when they own
the business it's doing really well it's
flying they know that they're in terms
of the financial ins incentives they're
going to do just fine and they can have
a really easy life and i've seen it
happen they just step back yeah they
just tiptoe out the door and let other
people do the hard graft why did you
want to step back into the hardest role
of all so first and foremost
i think like i said i've done all these
roles and i've built up to a point where
i
sort of thought i won't be able to do it
and i think the fact that so steve came
to me two years prior to coming to the
job and he said if you almost like i
think you can do this so that was a huge
vote of confidence because we'd had this
wasn't like an overnight thing right
this was a two-year build up from the
first conversation steve had to me
that's and his conversation was i think
i've taken the business to a point
where i can which is which was great uh
that he would be so honest and open
about that and then we had a two-year
period of okay like
are we gonna bring someone in from the
outside or ben are you gonna be able to
do this role and you know again similar
to what i did in 2015 is these are the
things that i now need to do to be good
enough to do in that role um so there
was a long almost warm-up handover
whatever you want to call it to that
now
the other thing i would say is the
business today is a very different place
to where it was like i don't know what
the numbers are but prior to steve we
were maybe 30 30 employees now we're
900. we were one office in the midlands
now we're several offices around the
world so it's a very very different
place
but
doing the chief of brand when the
business was this big and then product
at this big they're markets in it this
big and tech and so on
having the intricate understanding of
those areas not every area of the
business but many of the areas has
really helped as well one of the things
you said is that your link to that is
i'm scared of being someone that can
only just start the business and not run
it
yeah what do you mean by that i
so i i'm this i'm so proud of the fact
that i've found a gymshark i am it's
it's it's so great
but i don't want
i don't want it to be a bit like ben
founder of the business and that's all
he did like i want to do way more than
that and for me with my personality and
the way i'm built it's i think it's a
it's a bit it's a far bigger challenge
for me to run jim shark at the scale it
is now as a chief exec than it is to
start the business right
like there are so many business that
businesses that are started that die
after year one after year two after year
three after year four and five for me
i'm proud of the fact that i founded the
business i'm proud of the fact that i've
worked in the chiefs roles
but to be
in the front seat in the ceo
role a business like jim sharp moving
forward is one is the most exciting
thing in the world for me it's the
biggest challenge that i could possibly
like go for
and like for me that's exciting like i
want to aim
high both for the business but also
personally for myself as well and like
you said at the start i love learning
that doesn't mean i sit there reading
books 24 7 but i love learning and being
amongst it and there's no better role
for that
but the
apparent downside to that role is that
you then the box stops with you yeah
which means when there's problems when
there's crises they stop with you and
you could sail off into the distance
you'd get a really big boat with your
shareholding uh in the company and you
could just relax and just maybe
you know chill out maybe even invest in
some stuff and you know you and robin
can have a great life yeah why not
because it's like you're choosing
stress and long hours and busyness over
um
i think robin probably asked me the same
question regularly if i'm honest um
i genuinely love it i love the people
that i work with and you're right there
i i do not have to do this job there are
there is no two ways about it
i do it
purely because i absolutely adore it and
i want to challenge myself and i want to
be the best version of myself possible
when i have genuine ambitions to be a
great chief exec of this business one
day i don't think i'm anywhere near
there now
and it's a bit like you know someone has
to be a great ceo in five 10 20 years
time so why not me and
i'm always ambitious on behalf of the
business more than i am myself right so
i'll always put the business first
because it is my baby and i've been
there from
so in the close in the early days going
to the first events like looking at
having no money in the bank because of
the risk that we've taken so the
business for me always comes first and
the people within the business always
come first but personally i'm also
ambitious for myself as well
who is um hurricane ben hurricane ben
that would have been the
the ben that would have been described
prior to my 360 feedback so that i'll
give an example right so there would be
a
particular product that i didn't like
and my opinion would be just direct
brutal and probably not take into
account other people's feelings or
thoughts and that's not to say that
everything that you should do in
business should always be
you know stepping around people's
feelings because i definitely don't
think that's the way but equally like
don't be a dick and there was definitely
times in the early days when i was a bit
of a dick
and you and so what happens now in terms
of how have you learned not to be a dick
uh learn to give feedback
examples with feedback empathy
understanding why people do certain
things
like understanding the fact that like
you know no one is perfect certainly not
me nor anyone and
pretty much
never have i seen someone
go out of their way to like damage the
brand like people are doing things for
good intentions no one's designed a
product in a particular way because
they you know they want to see the brand
negative negatively affected no one's
posted on social or done something in
particular because they want to see the
brand negatively effective it's
essentially a difference of opinion so i
think
like understanding that and being aware
of it whilst i'm giving feedback i think
it's important what i'm in your because
i have this a lot as well what are the
some of the character traits you see in
people that work with you in in your
organization that you
you don't like so don't lie you don't
like so if you because because if if i
asked my team if i said to them what are
some of the things that steve doesn't
like from in terms of character
perspective okay
they would they would know i feel like
they would know because
and so to be fair i don't get too much
of this but i just don't want people to
agree with me because like i want to be
challenged all the time like for me
we want the best outcome i don't care if
it's my opinion or your opinion i want
the best outcome and if my idea is crap
tell me it's cool it's fine i will not
take it personally so i don't want
people i don't want like you know the
whole thing of a yes man yes person
whatever you want to call it i think
it's not to say that i don't like it but
i know that individuals that really
struggle with change don't tend to do
well at companies like jim shark if you
just want
a nine to five that is going to be
consistent and stay the same then it's
definitely not the right place for you
because it's so rapidly changing not
only because of the business itself but
because of the world that we're in like
10 years ago facebook was only small
snapchat didn't really exist
instagram barely existed
um shopify was very small like the
ecosystem in the world that we play in
was completely different so change as
well i think is important
yeah i can completely agree and uh i've
i've heard a few of your friends and
people within your team describe you as
being a bit of a perfectionist as well
in terms of having a high sort of
attention of detail is that do you
consider yourself to have to be a
perfectionist
i don't know
i don't think so i definitely don't have
a massive attention to detail i've got
the attention span of a nat really um
i try if if it's something that's really
i don't know something that just like
aligns with me then i'll i can obsess
over it for months on end um
if it's something i don't find
particularly interesting i have to use
every ounce of strength of every cell in
my body to remain focused on it like i
find that really difficult
i don't know if i'm a perfectionist i'm
probably not the best person to comment
on that i wouldn't say so i don't i
don't look like a perfectionist i'm a
bit scruffy and i you know i sort of
that's interesting meander
for those that can't see ben now he's
wearing his um it's all jim shark right
other than the shoes right yeah exactly
that um and you wear this outfit a lot
yeah
you pretty much look pretty the same
every day yeah why
because speed efficiency just simple no
messing around i don't have to sit and
think about i don't know what am i going
to wear today or i don't know anything
like that it literally just goes if it's
simple comfortable and i like it one of
the things you've started recently as
well as your vlog online um
and if we go back to when i that day
that i first met you and i i could tell
that you you know you were nervous in
that context and the guy you are today
two questions for you yeah um
did you did you do some sort of um did
you have professional support in
developing your ability to speak so
fluently and articulate your ideas so
well
um and then we'll move on to chatting
about why you're doing the vlog so i so
there's two things so public speaking
one in front of a camera two in front of
an audience or whatever you want to call
it to uh
to a group
i found those as two very different
things
and it's weird right because if i so
steve would be great in front of an
audience or struggle in front of a
camera
i was fortunate my other half robin was
a youtuber so she's brilliant in front
of a camera and she taught me how to
work in front of a camera basically not
through
uh i don't know i don't know it was just
through brute just keep going keep going
stick it for a camera in front of me the
first vlog she recorded and edited the
whole thing
um so she taught me how to sort of work
in front of a camera
i did have public speaking lessons
and that was massively life-changing for
me and the um going back to that list of
of things by the way when i said about
these are the things i'm good at these
are things i'm bad at one of those
things was public speaking
um and this is why i'm such a massive
advocate of making a list right because
public speaking was one of the many
things on my list which was a weakness
but i didn't then immediately go and
draw out a plan i just had that list and
i said i know i think i had it as my
wallpaper on my phone public speaking is
something i'm bad at
and then i was at an event or something
i remember what it was i think there was
an event at gymshark
and i'm chatting away to people chatting
away chatting away and said hello i'm
ben how are you have a great day you
know what do you do
and someone said i'm a public speaking
coach and then all of a sudden i've gone
boom light bulb i'm terrible at public
speaking you're a public speaking coach
i was like can you teach me
and and that's literally how it happened
but if i hadn't have sat there done that
work and written it down
it probably would have gone gone on
right i probably would have said okay
enjoy your day i'll see you soon it's
lovely to meet you and then i had public
speaking lessons i did i did actually um
shopify actually put me on a public
speaking sort of camera thing which was
cool then i did some here back in the uk
and just slowly worked it and and then
the thing that really helped me was just
and i wouldn't probably do this now due
to time but he was just saying yes to
things just saying yep i'm gonna do it
and you know what i'm gonna make a fall
on myself i'm sure there's some footage
somewhere of me
sweating and shuffling around a stage
somewhere like falling over my words and
being terrible at it but
you know that's just a necessary evil to
get get good at
anything really what did the public
speaking lessons was there like key
principles or key exercises that that
you felt actually moved the needle for
you was there anything there that maybe
someone listening to this that's a
really bad speaker might
be able to steal
there's a um there's a few bits so
there's one that that they told me and
there's a there's a quote i've said
online i think it's a winston church or
quote whether it is true you know you
see all these quotes and whether or not
they're true or not there's one where he
it says um i'm just preparing my
impromptu remarks which is like
obviously impromptu remark is a quick
sort of like thing that you've sort of
made up on the spot
and that really stuck with me because
then i know a lot of other people do
this as well is when we're talking about
a particular subject now i'm fortunate
because i've i've done so much of this
i've got like all these different
sentences and phrases and things that i
can draw on but in the early days it's
like so ben you're going to talk about
you're going to publicly talk about the
jim sharp story
now historically even though i knew the
gym shot story inside out because i was
there um i'd struggle with that so what
i do is i prepare phrases sentences
words reminders in my head so if someone
said i don't know talk to me about the
first event it would just sort of roll
off the tongue and granted i probably
wouldn't do that any anymore
but in the early days that got me over
that hump of that nervousness that frog
in my throat i don't know where to start
because that's the main thing is once
you've started it's fine right it just
goes but even just having that first
sentence of oh the first event was body
power and we did this and this and this
and then it yeah that that really helped
me that's so funny because that's
exactly what happens from practice isn't
it you'll know that now just go back to
it exactly i you know when i i do a lot
of interviewing interviews and stuff too
and there's like keywords trigger story
so if you said to me um
rejection i'd be like oh yeah you know
and then it's just the same old and that
and that's so funny because that's
ultimately what you're saying you're
yeah and coaching so yeah so first and
foremost preparing impromptu remarks
whatever you want to call it prepare
stories prepare things like make sure
you're well prepared and generally you
want to
if you're not very good at it like for
me i had to over prepare i had to
prepare you know this many things for a
conversation that was this long
um and then the aim of that is to become
comfortable that's the main thing and
that was really that was the biggest
difficulty for me become comfortable so
now i'm super fortunate you could put me
on a stage in front of a thousand people
and i would i mean it'd be a bit
peculiar if i wasn't prepared but you
know i'd be fine i'd be comfortable
because then once you're comfortable
what you do is you buy yourself time so
then if we're on stage and you asked me
a question five years ago i'd probably
like panic and answer as quickly as i
can with whatever
whereas now
i'm gonna process it think about it and
then come back with a response because
i'm comfortable and like i think the
stages to all different types of
learning and that was it for me one
preparation once i'd done that i'd
learnt to be comfortable and then i
learned about you know different things
as i go on and you know so this has led
you to now because you know what you're
i watched your videos back then and
maybe this is why i was surprised when i
met you because you're on your videos i
genuinely thought you were amazing you
could take ten thousand hundred and
twenty three that's why yeah i watched
your videos on youtube i was like this
guy's an unbelievable speaker oh no and
then i met you in person and it wasn't
that you're about like he's a shuffling
mess no it was so the crazy thing is you
weren't a bad speaker and your stories
were amazing but it was i could just
tell you were nervous yeah and that was
and that's what you were speaking today
about being comfortable
some people are just naturally
comfortable and that's and that's cool
and i think that but that's the main
thing and i do think for whatever reason
i think it's probably maybe we're not
taught it maybe it just doesn't feel
natural
if you can and by the way if you can
speak publicly if you can speak to
cameron if you can speak to groups
that is so powerful
so powerful it's untrue
why should you drink fuel we're going
into the fourth quarter of the year
diets are dropping off we're becoming
lazier and lazier and what tends to
happen when when our diets dip and we we
start to become less um compelled to go
to the gym
is yeah we get out of shape we start to
feel low energy we start to binge eat
bad things and fuel is the antidote it's
nutritionally complete so you get
everything you need for your diet in a
drink you get your 20 grams of proteins
you're going to get your 26 vitamins and
vitamins and minerals
it's low sugar high in fiber it really
is the cure to a lot of the health
issues that we see in our personal lives
but in wider society if you've never
tried it all i'll ask you to do is give
it a try and if you like me then you
will like the world berry ready to drink
you'll like the mac and cheese which is
just selling like absolutely crazy
unsurprisingly um
you like the cinnamon
and you like the banana flavor those are
my recommendations i know a lot of
people love the chocolate flavor
let me know try it get yourself healthy
and send me a message on instagram tag
me on instagram as well on your stories
if you do try it out because i i
sometimes upload those tags
and let me know which is your favorite
flavor can't wait from you
you now run
what was voted i think 2016 2017 one the
fastest growing company in this country
it's still one of the fastest growing
companies in this country it's worth
billions and billions and billions
um and you've decided that you're going
to vlog inside the company this is not
what ceos do ben
they don't you don't see them you never
get to
you know like think about all the big
companies it's very controlled pr yeah
why why do you think that matters
because if we go back to
me on the inside working with my grandad
and being able to learn about those
stories that eventually
led to in many ways the gym shot we see
today
i think
i would love to be able to provide that
to other people around the world
particularly here first and foremost it
can be done right so you can start a
business
in the uk whatever in in this world
online and it can become a unicorn in
under 10 years and if you don't want to
you don't have to go and borrow a load
of money you don't have to highly
leverage yourself if you're a problem
solver you're open-minded and you're
self-aware it can be done and i think
one that i think that's the first sort
of like step for me let me come at that
one then because i know because i i know
what people are saying they're saying
ben no that's you know it's called good
or well and good you saying that because
you've done it but
i can't i can't do it i'm i don't know
what you know and i'm uh i don't you
know i don't know anything about
computers and
it's all well and good you saying that
but you were this is what people say
because they said to me well you were
lucky you know you're timing and
by the way i was incredibly lucky
massively lucky you're good and that
would be completely right
um
and listen i would completely understand
that but
for the for some that want to
then that to me is is a proof of when it
can be done now
i am
very well aware of the fact that i was
very lucky one in the people i've met
two in terms of timing so fitness was on
the up right in the early 2000s all over
the news was obesity right to rise in so
fitness was on the up because people
were encouraging people into the gym and
fitness um
direct to consumer came out of nowhere
people were more comfortable in the sort
of 2010s than ever buying things online
right in the early 2000s
people were weren't that comfortable
buying online from a company they had
never heard of let alone one from right
another country abroad but number three
we had social media those three forces
converging at the point where jim sharp
was founded
is completely and utterly look and i do
understand that but i'm also aware of
the fact that there's loads of those
things happening elsewhere in the world
right now that you know probably aren't
being completely taken advantage of
so
i am aware of the fact that it's luck
but i also think as well in me doing
this i'd like to think that regardless
even if you don't want to start your own
business which by the way is completely
cool like and i'd probably say in many
respects that's probably a good idea
because it is very difficult to do this
um
i still think there's lessons that can
be learnt and i love the thought of
people being able to take something away
from the gymshark story and create
something called of their own
it also gives you this weird type of
defense
because you can see that so many ceos
have been attacked because they are in
essence i think what we're talking about
here is being like a glass box ceo or
the old model of being like a black box
ceo yeah where your image is painted on
the outside by your marketing or pr
people and no one ever gets to really
know you'll see inside you've taken this
really glass box approach where if
someone writes something bad about you
ben i can like well i've seen 65
interviews of him and i've seen his vlog
so i have my own reference point to know
that that's actually not him and some
ceos out there like elon and these
really public ones have that and then
zuckerberg hidden a k for the last 10
years and in 2019 he announced that he
was finally going to start doing
interviews because of how everyone just
thought he was this emotionless robot
because that's what the press said yeah
um and it is this this incredible
defense mechanism that i don't think
people really appreciate
yeah and i think i can also empathize i
mean listen what zuckerberg has done is
like on a completely other world to what
any pretty much anyone else has done
certainly myself um but in the early
days of gymshark i didn't want to be
clustering myself on social media by the
way i didn't want to be on youtube i
wanted to just knuckle down and focus on
building the business because remember i
didn't know what it would be at that
point
it was only when
people started asking for that that i
then decided to do it so i do also
understand the idea of just knuckling
down and focusing on what you're good at
but you're right the problem that comes
with is
other people get to control
the rhetoric or the language or the
description of yourself and we're seeing
that in the uk a lot of big companies in
the uk that are being attacked at the
moment
you don't know whether the articles are
true because you don't know the person
they're talking about and um that's why
i literally have a picture in my office
over there reveal on smoking's uh joint
on the joe rogan podcast because for me
and this is going to sound like [ __ ]
bonkers like that's the ceo i would want
to be
is where i cry on jurgen's podcast
smoking a joint and for everyone to know
that that's how open i am and yeah much
the reason why i started this so the
pandemic comes around
um
talk me through how it was being a ceo
throughout that because one of the
really remarkable things is you didn't
follow anybody you didn't no we didn't
so i wasn't ceo at the start of covid i
came in in august but the so that was
interesting so we we were lucky again
because we were completely set up the
zoom everyone has laptops we're you know
we're a digital business so working from
home thanks to our tech team and in the
investments they made
from a systems perspective it wasn't
like tough i know there are other
companies that not everyone had a laptop
and so on so that i couldn't imagine
where to start there
um and we had that moment where
so what we have is because we have we
have an office in hong kong we have
offices in the uk we have offices in the
us and we literally saw because kovid
sort of came from the
east to the west didn't it and we saw
hong kong
closed right everyone went into lockdown
and there was this bit where i know i
was thinking never happened here never
happened here
until it did right and then
boom locked down everyone working from
home and um i was in what was i doing at
that point i think i was just finished
opening marketing and i think i was
moving into product at that point
and the moment that caught me which was
within like 24 hours of being locked
down
i was lucky i have an office at home i
shut the door i've got a desk and i can
just work through that and when i'm
finished i can close the door at the end
of the day i was chatting to someone and
they were like they were in a studio
apartment in birmingham city center and
their partner was making their breakfast
behind them and they were sort of like
like balancing their laptop on the work
surface and
it was all just i remember chatting to
her and thinking okay this is going to
be really just really tough for some
people
from a professional perspective and then
i'm chatting to my mom who worked at the
qe in birmingham city center uh hospital
in selly oak she was telling me about
what was going on there and i was like
it was very
i became very aware very quickly that
this was a big thing or it was going to
be a big thing um so yeah managing
through that was was really really
really tough um
listen commercially the business did
okay like people were shopping online
and it you know there were more people
working out from home they were cycling
they were running
that side of the business did well
but managing hundreds of staff around
the world working from home
mental health making sure that we're
supporting them
through
complete uncertainty was definitely
difficult and where did you learn then
so having seen that member of your team
on that ironing board in that studio
apartment where did you land on this
whole remote working debate um
what is jim shark what's that what's
your injury so we we i mean listen there
are people at jim sharp that work
remotely and it works for them and
that's fine
personally i'm a little bit
old-schooling i'm in the office pretty
much every day unless i'm you know out
at meetings i just love to be in the
office um that doesn't mean it's right
or wrong i'm sure i would probably do a
a day maybe a month or a quarter working
from home if i need to like work through
things because when we did work from
home i found that i finally got to my
to-do list which was useful and i'd
never really got to that previously
we're sort of open-minded there are some
people that remote work it makes sense
for them um as long as it makes sense
for the business as well as them that's
cool personally i like to be in the
office you you have this big amazing
office in the uk especially i mean you
have a few but the one in
birmingham yes
sully hall is a tremendous new like
newly built
campus almost that he's built um
what role does that play because i'm i'm
in the camp of i love the office as well
and i think it's i think it's more than
just a place where you come to do your
work i think it's community i think it's
culture i think it gives especially
younger generations who haven't figured
out their lives you have an opportunity
to learn meet people
get married
um so what like how do you see the
office and and have you set parameters
for your employees as to
we're working on it now that's what
we're trying to work through um there
are some people that are on remote
contracts so they choose to work remote
there are many the vast majority are on
contracts which which means they're
based in hq
um
personally you're right the whole thing
about like i said earlier being able to
watch steve right was massive for my
development so if i'm a youngster that's
coming in to work at gymshark i want to
be in the office i want to learn and i
want to grow and i want to be around
people because that's not to say you
can't learn on zoom i think you can and
i think there's great utility for zoom
and i think there's areas where it's
really helpful and useful
but if i'm a young product designer i
want to be around designers and i want
to be able to be inspired and i want to
have that conversation i want to be able
to share ideas in the moment rather than
having to jump on slack forward slash
resume jump on a call and so on
hopefully they're free
so yeah for me i like i said i like to
be in the office i think it's it's a
great place to learn and and the office
for us and which is why we're investing
in this campus and this larger office is
it is it's a hub of jim shark when
you're there you're in it we we work
together we eat together in refuel many
of us go and lift in the gym after
together and it builds that genuine
community in the build in the uh in the
business one of the things you you know
when i hear your story um no matter
where i look
it it does feel like you're just
incredibly good at dealing with [ __ ]
like it it appears on the surface that
you're just incredibly good at dealing
with the hard times um and it also kind
of appears that other than the one
moment you told me about where you the
website went down and you had to write
out the apology notes and stuff but
there's really not been a lot of like
chaos
and i'm like every every day is chaos
that's why tell me about that part of it
i don't know where to begin like in
terms of like starting the business
we there were several times we invested
everything we had on a particular event
or a particular product line
um
covid was tough it's like
what
when the business the business is
growing at the rate that we're growing
even just making sure that we've got
enough stock to fulfill the forecast for
the following year is it's tough to
manage and work out moving from you know
zero to 900 staff in nine years that's
so hard and it's like every day hard
because in many respects
when a big problem comes in and it just
hits you in out of nowhere
you look at that problem and you try and
solve it whereas people forget about the
everyday nagging problems of making sure
that like the majority of the people
that currently exist in gymshark weren't
in jim sharp 12 months ago so the
majority of people in jim sharp maybe
aren't as aware of the story or the way
that the business works or or haven't
been truly immersed in the culture both
because they haven't been here for a
long time but also because we have been
working remote for so long
so those problems in terms of making
sure that everyone is truly bought into
the brand are really important because
when you've got a team that big we want
to make sure that they're working
efficiently as well
steve said that um
the former ceo said that pressure is a
privilege
to you so i think it's true
do you think it's a privilege for you as
ben or do you think it's a privilege for
everybody i think it depends on what the
pressure is right right i'm sure there
are people in this world that are under
a lot of pressure that certainly doesn't
feel like a privilege but in the context
of jim shark is a privilege like we all
choose to be there we're all a part of
something really special something that
i really believe this i think
i do think books will be written on this
story and i think maybe if we do what we
think we can maybe like there'll be
programs and movies too because it is so
unique and so special so within the
context of gymshark i do think pressure
is well and truly a privilege for us
when i when i reflect on early days of
starting my business there was a lot of
unknown unknowns a lot of things i wish
someone had just told me sooner or a
lesson that it took me three or four
years to learn
when you look back at some of the things
you wish you knew sooner that would have
maybe even put
what is a phenomenal business even
further ahead
what are those things that come to mind
i'm interested in
interested to hear what you think but
for me given my skill set we didn't
invest in the foundations of the
business early enough i
i was
going back to being arrogant at the
start i didn't really respect what maybe
the ops or finance people of this world
did i the the foundation elements of the
business to me were nowhere near as
exciting or fun as the front end element
of the business the product the brand
and the marketing so i think if we'd
have better prepared ourselves for that
from a like i said data ops finance all
these things i think dream shop would
have grown far quicker
and i mean in terms of especially with
what you guys did particularly social
change you were ahead of your time in
that in terms of bringing all these
pages and channels together and almost
packaging them up for different
businesses and brands so
you must have struggled with that as
well oh my god my answer is the exact
same as yours it's just i was exact i
was exactly the same guy i
thought that the thing that would move
the needle most was what i did and what
i knew and then it wasn't until you hire
one really great person and you go
[ __ ] oh that's that's what good look
and look at all the things i don't know
and i i think it took me two maybe three
years to realize the importance of
really great talent yeah and that my
skills and my talents weren't actually
going to matter that much especially at
700 800 people business yeah the um i
think great people are amazing we did a
trip uh to fiji years and years ago and
it was the first time i got to spend
time with
harley uh shopify holly finkelstein and
uh toby wow at shopify so like these are
like some top top entrepreneurs and
there was there was a load of other
people there
i remember sat i didn't even barely say
anything i remember listening to them
and i was thinking to myself
jim sharks like uh
or the people or the certainly even me i
felt like i was like a local football
club player these are like premier
league international stars they were
like
another level compared to what i was and
we were in the business so to be able to
see those when you see a great operator
like look at zuckerberg people just look
at zuckerberg as like a guy or elon or
whatever these people are going to be so
efficient and frighteningly intelligent
and adaptable and resilient that
you without meeting them i genuinely
don't think you'll be able to fathom it
i obviously haven't met them having met
people like harley and toby they were on
another level to anyone that i'd met
before
um
and they're like they were just like us
at one point right they've had to work
they weren't just born hyper resilient
super intelligent open-minded and blah
blah blah
maybe a little bit in terms of
intelligence but a lot of the skills
that we see
from them they had to learn and they had
to work on
that was massively inspiring so i yeah i
think you're right i can't stress enough
how important it is to just try and
surround yourself with great people but
i was i was lucky right that trip most
people don't get to go on trips like
that they don't get to have their their
eyes opened um but there's still there's
great people in every community every
gym every whatever you can you can
definitely find them
i completely agree again i i um i came
to now learn in the businesses i start
and i say this to my teams all the time
in flightster and third web that we are
basically a recruitment company we're
like never forget that the most
important thing here and the thing that
is behind and initiates every decision
is a person a talent obviously it's
bound together with culture and a vision
but fundamentally um it was actually one
day i read on somewhere that the
definition of a company on google and in
the oxford dictionary is actually a
group of people
like that's what they said as a company
that's it means a group of people yeah
and i started thinking about that in
fact it's like a football team it's
where we are starting 11 and in
competitive industries and we're all in
competitive industries i start thinking
about it like a football team like this
is the guy i've got up in left back or
right wing against my competitors guy
or woman
and i started thinking [ __ ] hell
fundamentally i just need to be the best
talent as steve jobs says the best
talent scout in the world and i wasn't
until
this chapter of my life later on like
it's too late
yeah until too late and the
for me i think like in terms of getting
so you can talk about getting great
people becoming self-aware becoming the
best version of it yourself that you
possibly can be
and even that all of those things if you
did that incredibly well that by no
means guarantee success all that does is
increase the likelihood or the
probability of success even then you've
got a fairly slim chance because like i
said so many small businesses fail and
that's the other thing that i think
anyone starting out or whatever all
working the business needs to understand
is that
failure is inevitable don't be defined
by your failures it could be an
operation in the business it could be
the business itself
it's inevitable that it's going to
happen all you can do is do everything
within your power to minimize the
likelihood of that happening
talking about doing that which is within
your power you've managed to seemingly
avoid
um the the toll of business getting to
you my business partner's been very open
on this podcast about how the stress of
business made him anxious and then he
suffered with depression and then he
became in his own words basically like a
functional functional alcoholic
um
it doesn't seem to have touched you in
the same way i mean have you ever
experienced anxiety or yeah i've
listened i've definitely struggled there
were points where
again when i was first sort of i felt
like i was first going out on my own
um in 2015
there have been periods where
uh you know social media maybe has
turned on the business and myself
it's definitely been really difficult at
times there's been points where social
media turned on the business so we there
was a there was something that happened
last i think it was last year or the
year before
where
someone at gymshark on the channel on
the on the social channel basically
commented back to someone
um i can't remember exactly what we said
but basically it was around a blue lives
matter you know you had the sort of
black lives matter
someone commented uh something on our
page saying blue lives matter and
someone at jim sharp basically commented
something sarcastic back to them um
which to be honest was it it probably
just shouldn't have been posted and then
at that point that i think that whole
group of people started to converge onto
gymshark
um
and then before long they then started
to converge onto me and i had thousands
of comments thousands of messages death
threats everything you can imagine um
and that that was in that definitely hit
me and it definitely hurt me and i
really felt like i felt carrying that i
felt like i was carrying that burden at
that point
talk to me about that and so you the
world piles on
because of something someone else has
done on twitter whatever we won't go
into that too much but
the world piles on you're going on your
phone that's popping off your people are
probably texting you your family this is
the worst part you're family checking
yeah and it's like
you just don't want to look at your
phone yeah and that's
that like i said that was really
difficult for me really tough
um did you feel anxious you felt that
sense of like i felt horrible i felt
like you have a lump in your throat you
feel sick you don't look at it yeah then
you don't want to look at your phone um
i
i struggled with that but i think i had
support at work
and
there's a quote that i've heard no no
was the one that told me about it
and the quote goes something like
to whom much is
to whom much is given which is tested i
think it's roughly like that and i do
think about that a lot i i'm in this
role i'm in this job and i'm so
privileged and fortunate to be here i've
worked incredibly hard but i am
fortunate and inevitably
much has been given to me so much will
be tested of me and that to me is one of
many and there'll be more in the future
that will happen again and i have to be
well aware of it and open to it and
understanding of it what did that moment
teach you
i think it's
it was a so that was a bout of
resilience so going back to what i said
earlier every day i feel like i have to
be resilient in terms of having hard
conversations in terms of challenging
people in terms of
you know trying to move the business
forward in the right way whereas that
was like boom you need to be resilient
now because the other thing as well that
again i'm sure you will know this that
happens and i'm feeling terrible as it's
happening but there's still a business
with hundreds of people that need help
support you know all these things so i
can't like i can't just shy away and
feel sad for a week
or at least it can't appear to be like
that i mean i can feel those emotions i
can process them but ultimately the
business comes first and i have to
support the business and the individuals
within it and
that was that was
an interesting challenge for me to face
because again i can't just mope around
the office i come into the office and
i'm
it's to me it's like it's like a game of
football i'm there to perform to deliver
and i
you know we want to win we want to
create great things and
i don't want to
let this thing rightly or wrongly sort
of drag me down two questions then how
do you
handle the situation with the employee
that posted that comment which ended up
getting you piled on and
you know felt at least like you were
being cancelled
they had no bad intention so yeah they
stayed at the business and now they they
do an incredible job they were a great
person so i i really don't believe in
cancer culture i think especially when
uh people do things by mistake and this
certainly was a mistake and they learned
from the mistake and now they're a
better stronger more educated and
informed person because of it and i
think that's
um that's the way it is like i that what
you can't have at gymshark or anywhere
you can't have someone that fails
particularly with good intentions and
then
you just
move them out of the business because
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to create change we're trying to create
progress and a great business and if
every time someone failed you just move
them out the business then all you'll be
left with is with a group of people that
have never failed
and that's dangerous
so yeah they're still in the business
and they're doing great work and the
other question was when you go home that
day
and robin's there
what's that like uh she's incredibly
supportive i think she gets it because
and this is this helps as well because
she has had time online she did do the
whole youtube thing and the social media
thing so she does understand what it's
like so she's
um
incredibly supportive did you
rant to her did you
so that's probably something i'm not
very good at i'm not i don't
talk about my feelings massively i'm not
that sort of person i don't know why i
don't know it's just if i look at the
way my dad is my grandparents are the
males that around me growing up they're
very strong individuals they're very
like i wouldn't
often hear them talk about feelings
which is fine and it's cool i get it
it's probably not the most optimal
solution and i'm learning to do that but
um
it's given me great resilience it's made
me strong
um
definitely made me mentally strong so
yeah i'll i'll chat to robin i think
she'll try and pry information from me
and i'll i'll chat to her does she does
she succeed i mean my girlfriend does
the same my girlfriend is the the
ultimate person in my life of trying to
make me express how i'm feeling
emotionally and again like you said
naturally it's not my default state
especially it almost makes me feel
uncomfortable like i'd love to sit here
and talk to you about how i am
completely open and in touch with every
single feeling that i'm feeling i wish
maybe that's something i need to work on
but that certainly isn't true i
i do understand and i process those
feelings i'm definitely not as
communicative as what i probably should
be on those things i like to sort of
internalize them and process them
without talking about them too much we
we've seen obviously in headlines and
stuff around mental health and men in
particular not talking about the
feelings the adverse consequences of not
sharing your feelings the other thing
which i learned recently is from patrice
evra when he came and we talked about
toxic masculinity and again his he was
telling me his girlfriend was the one
who
um
helped him open up his feelings because
he was very you know growing up on the
streets of france drug dealing trying to
survive et cetera um the risk is it
becomes a generational cycle you've
pointed to the fact that it probably was
a generational cycle for you
um death prob definitely was for me i've
never had my dad express a feeling in
his life
so now you're married and you know
one would assume that there's going to
be kids at some point potentially
is that something you think about like
the
uh
i don't know
i mean listen
if i had a kid
i would definitely want them to tell me
about how they're feeling because i'd
rather know what's going on than not so
yeah maybe that is something i would
push with them robin certainly will yeah
robin will yeah um and the other point
on the kid thing it just triggered
something i've been thinking about
lately in my life is how present are you
gonna be i i'm i'm gonna be honest i'm
scared
i'm scared because um if things carry on
as they are now i'm like sometimes i
forget to walk my dog and my assistant
does it for me and when i when i have
kids i don't want to be that business
guy that's never ceased his kids i want
to be president in their lives i want to
take them to school pick them up again
like you know so do you think about that
yeah change you might have to make
because we don't have kids i haven't
thought about it massively i think um
there was a few things so steve advised
me he said
be there for the sports days
he doesn't i don't think he means be
there for the sports days i think he me
it's like a thing like be there be
present and be there when the kid wants
you to be so that's something i would
definitely like to do
i don't know
my dad worked away a lot as a kid
and
i don't feel like i was adversely
affected by it
maybe i'm wrong maybe i have been um but
it's not even when i said when i started
traveling
and being away for long periods of time
there was periods where i'd do 30 40 50
flights a year and i'd be away all the
time and that wasn't like abnormal that
was like my mom was like cool with that
she gets it's fine my dad would work a
lot in like the states in europe and
stuff and then my mom would look after
us so i'd go and stay with my
grandparents for a while
um
again i'm not saying that's optimal
but i
i was i felt like i was fine growing up
i i actually spoke so i've got uh i'm
working with a new ea called zoe who's
absolutely been life changing for me
like genuinely life-changing and she has
two kids and we were talking about it
actually the other day
um
and we sort of we do this thing we
monday morning first thing we look
through the calendar for the week and
then she sort of made a bit of a comment
she was like are you still gonna be able
to do this if you have kids
um and and i was sort of like is that a
loaded question like you asked are you
telling me that i won't be able to do
this and um
what helps having zoe is i think because
she has kids she knows what it's like i
think she'll help me manage it as it
comes and then her thing was
no you won't be able to work like this
but if we plan for it and we work things
out then we can work out a way to make
it work which is great i'm sure robin
will be happy with that as well
if i'm in the ceo role which i hope i am
i'm not going to be at home every single
day at half five monday to friday it's
it's it's just one of the things that
comes with the job
there's been a lot written about what
the future of jim shark looks like a lot
of speculating a lot of guessing as to
what route you're going to take a lot of
people at this point probably would have
already sold the company to a bigger
nike or an adidas or whoever it might be
what can you tell me about the future of
jim shark
so my ambition is to make so
so in canada you've got lulu in the
united states you've got um
nike and drama and in germany you've got
adi and puma so first and foremost i
want jim sharp to be
the
british fitness brand right i want you i
think it's really cool so growing up i
grew up not far away from the rover mg
factories in longbridge um
it was a really cool british brand
unfortunately it didn't end or i mean mg
still going it didn't end probably as
they would have liked um over in sully
hall jaguar land rover uh cool british
but international brands uh burberry
aston martin like bentley and rolls
royce like these are so cool and i think
i love the thought of a brand that was
grown here he's headquartered here but
he's a truly global brand and i think
that's really really cool i love the
thought of that
um
now emphasis on the fact i want jim
chart to be a global brand we we sell
into
like the entire world at the moment like
a lot of the the revenue and the
customers and the community of gymshark
are international the uk is a small
um area of that now because of the
growth we've seen in north america
europe and so on so my ambition is for
gymshark to be
a truly truly global brand and one of
the most iconic brands in the world i
think that's so it's so cool the thought
of jim sharp being a truly iconic brand
a brand that's sort of like
like genuinely pulls people together and
inspires people to be
the best version of themselves both
physically and mentally and he's in many
ways
the
like the manifestation of this journey
that i feel like i've gone on from
joining the gym and trying to improve
myself physically and then mentally
through the business and so on i think
that's really cool but ultimately i want
it to be one of the most iconic brands
in the world and then however you
structure that in the back front
whatever you do to make that happen i'm
almost like channel agnostic i just want
jim sharp to be a truly iconic great
brand that
is like a true leader in culture and
helps inspire people around the world 10
years time we wake up
jim shark is a truly iconic british
brand
globally you've done it
now what i'll be really sad i'll have
nothing to do um no i'm not sure at that
point i don't know it's so funny because
your answer there is exactly what gary
vaynerchuk said he said he was like that
would be the worst day of my life
oh when he um when he buys the jets
i don't know um
isn't that funny the thing you aim for
will be the saddest day of your life is
scary isn't it but will you i don't know
how you would put a pin in that like if
gary bought the jets he owns the jets
yeah how would you put a pin in the fact
that jim shark when did gymshark become
iconic it's true like when when does
that tipping point happen um you'll have
to let me know if that happens i think
that's so that's a really interesting
point there because what it what it
actually says is that all the fun is
actually the journey and if you do want
to set yourself up to never have that
awful day then create a goal that like
they say the best journeys are the ones
with no destination
and so you're right this is uh there's
no day there's no measurement of that
it's a continual process and also at
times you'll get things pop the world
will change and we all might go to the
metaverse yeah and that's going to be a
whole new challenge for you to maintain
the position so
like through the yeah this that is
mental we were talking about the other
day about how just how much the world's
going to change in the next 10 years and
then going back to the start about
someone that's starting up
so once he's considering starting a
business or
or anything like that is like
that becomes easier or it happens with
change and like looking forward the
amount of change we are about to see is
unfathomable i am convinced of it it is
going to be crazy and the opportunities
will be huge
you have 900 people roughly now right
how do you turn a 900 person company uh
in a new direction really hard what are
you doing from like in a very practical
sense to set the team up for
so in terms of nuts and bolts we'll have
something that we call a brand book
which is brand guidelines this is what
we do this is what we don't do we'll
have a strategic page which says these
are the core things that we want to do
these are force or strategic initiatives
that sit outside of the day-to-day
outside of what you might see
that jim shark are currently doing and
then we'll basically put resource behind
those initiatives um
to basically see what happens some of
them might fail some of them might win
i'm not sure um that's a really boring
way of explaining how we do it and is
there like a cultural thing as well
around like some you know because so
many companies they get big doing one
thing yeah
web two let's call it you know social
media whatever it might be and then the
world changes and because they are so
big as you've said it becomes actually
their biggest weakness yeah especially
in advertising like in our industry the
reason why social change did so well was
because the incumbents were all into
like billboards and tv yeah and radio
and it was like a mindset thing they
couldn't change fast enough which gave
us this window like you've described
macro factors with this surfboard we
surf in
and we'd capitalize on them the moment
yeah
um is there a mindset thing a way that
you speak to your teams to make sure
they're like mentally
well no but like i said as people are
joining the business and coming in we're
super we make them aware that this is a
place where change is inevitable and
oftentimes you don't even know what that
is right like the biggest problem jim
sharp will experience in the next five
years we've got no idea what it is and
one day whether it's tomorrow or in two
years or in four years it's gonna hit us
and blindside us in the head and knock
us for six and we'll have to adjust
adapt and change to deal with it um and
we've we're aware of that we talk about
that a lot we we do talk about change
and we try and like prime everyone to be
prepared and ready for the fact that
things will change like on a day-to-day
basis things change from structures to
the way that we want to you know achieve
certain things
and sometimes they can be difficult but
ultimately that's a lot easier to deal
with but i think those things happening
the constant change of a growing
business creates a culture of a culture
of change when these things do happen
i'd like to think we're in a reasonable
situation to deal with it and we are
agile as well with thin we're like
we don't have
like 900 people's a lot not compared to
some of the larger competitors they have
thousands and thousands and thousands of
employees all around the world they have
lots of different distributors they have
lots of different stores like hundreds
if not thousands of different moving
parts all the right all the way around
the world today jim shark is in his most
basic form
a website
one website and that is where you buy
jim sharp from
speaking of change then um the high
street
shut down this year fortunately as
you've described you're in a good
position because you are a direct
consumer yep um and
why have you never opened up a store on
the high street why have you always you
know stayed away from that
just time resource
there are
in a fast-growing business you will
you'll you'll have to say no to so many
things because if you said yes to
everything you would end up just
watering your business down it would end
up just being
you know it would be too gary used this
term we spoke to him the other day he
said you never want jim char to become a
vanilla boulder just you don't want to
become vanilla right
so it was it's purely down to a down to
a resource thing historically so if i
look at what we would coin as offline
jim shark's been heavily involved in
offline since day one the first ever
blow up of the brand
was through an offline event
um and then we did expose around the
world and we spent every single penny we
had flying around the world now in our
early 20s doing these events
then after that
we wondered
are there people coming to the event
because of to see jim shark or our
people happen to be at the event and
they come to gymshark so we thought how
can we find out how many people really
want to come and see gymshark we
actually did a
test in covent garden we wanted to do a
one-month story in covent garden uh two
weeks in cove it happened and we had to
close the whole thing
um
i'm massively inspired by
different businesses and what they do
off in their offline so
i think the opportunities on the high
street are massive would you ever
well we will at some point um
so touchwood
we are i'm hoping in the next sort of
few days to be able to sign a lease on a
store um in london our first ever store
would be a flagship and it will be a
hopefully a community hub for jim shot
our first ever
perm permanent offline
store hub whatever you want to call it
this is so early in the process like i
said we haven't even signed a lease yet
so
um
fingers crossed that will go through
we're just working through that now and
again we've got a vision of this being a
a true
gymshark community hub
that's so interesting because that
really does feel like the future of the
high street really experienced base not
somewhere you're going to buy and sell
things but
truly experienced based and
community-centric because as well what
we need to think about is what we're
trying to build here is a brand
and what we don't want is something that
is purely based on utility and what i
mean is
i don't want people to buy gymshark
because it's quicker cheaper and easier
like i think we should try and be those
things to a degree but it's not purely
utility thing if you want that go to
amazon right amazon will give you
everything that you need rapid cheap and
that's cool and i love the business i
shop from them all the time
but for me gymshark is a brand and it is
a brand and it's a feeling and it's that
badge of honor that you wear it's that
that that dedication to self-improvement
both physical and mental and to do that
we need a community and that's the wider
gymshark community the people that
follow us all across instagram snapchat
you know ticks off all these different
channels
and then the events have always been the
culmination of that community when
you're there and it's just like
everyone's there and they have these
sort of inherent
um like similarities and they've got
that same mindset and it's such an
amazing place to be
so we thought what if we could do that
permanently which is what hopefully this
store will be
when your brand gets bigger and brands
you know many brands have kind of fallen
foul of this it's it's really hard to
hold on to the brand piece right there
yeah what's your strategy towards as you
scale all around the world
what's going to happen right is if i
walk into my gym muscle works down the
road and everyone is wearing gym shark i
might be like [ __ ] that i don't want to
be that guy right like yeah and then
your brand is almost doing a lot of work
for you on the ground because of the
scale so how do you hold on to that core
specialness i think
well first and foremost i think so jim
shark it's still quite a niche brand in
the sense that we're not doing
sportswear right you won't see people on
the football pitch wearing gymshark you
won't see people on play like on the
basketball court wearing gymshark
gymshark is built to be worn in the gym
like granted you know there's odd bits
to sort of to and from stuff that i'll
wear in the office or and in the gym as
well but i think by staying true to that
core by focusing
completely and early on building the
best gym product whether it's clothing
whether it's accessories whatever it is
we might create down the line i think by
doing that i think we can um
we shouldn't water our brand down too
much and you know that specialness
because you've been there since the
start so if i remove ben what happens in
your honest opinion if i was to remove
you from your business whereas what
happens to your business in 10 years
time i think it will continue i'm not
sure who would immediate like being four
months in i'm not sure who would
immediately step into the role
probably the best argument would be
steve but we we've got a proper
management team like we've got like our
chief of product is infinitely better
than i will ever be at product achieve a
brand is infinitely better than i will
be the commercial team that we've run
across international and now they're
both way better than me but there's a
specialness with a founder because they
they can see all of the dots they've
been there for 10 years and they can see
why this truly from day one why this
brand is special like i genuinely
believe no one can even in leaving my
business i'm going to be honest
i know the specialness my business has
lost it doesn't mean my business isn't
going to make great revenues for the
next five ten years but i know that
there's going to be a loss in vision and
culture and like specialness that um
it's hard to replace yeah and is that
this dude maybe i don't know because i
know that a lot of people like to work
in the business because they're so close
to it like it feels like you're in a
movie like it genuinely feels like that
because
we'll sit at lunch and we'll talk about
like the stories of jim shark like
we'll go and lift in the gym after work
with just random people that have just
joined the business and
maybe maybe that would disappear i don't
know you're right in terms of the
commercials of the business wouldn't
change the brand is so well run and the
vision the plan is so robust
like they'll present brand plans for the
next two years to me
and i'll just sit there nodding
and that's amazing that's really that's
really amazing
that's like a testament again i know
you're gonna
give give the credit but that's that's
what the promised land for all founders
is to be to build such a team that
you're effectively redundant right
and you've done that i wanna i know that
there's gonna be a lot of young
entrepreneurs watching this and i know
that they typically ask me the same
question so i want to ask you just a
couple of them before we wrap one of
them i get a lot is you know there'll be
someone listening to this they've not
got any money yeah um they want to start
a business they
don't have an idea but they want to
start a business what would you say to
them
they're going to you don't have an or
money yeah but they want they want to be
an entrepreneur i get this a lot
so
the first thing for me would be to find
out what you're truly truly passionate
about because
for me when i started gymshark
i made two fitness apps beforehand i
made two fitness apps both failed
miserably i made a little fitness social
network failed miserably a little
fitness sort of forum that failed
miserably and then jim sharp was it
i wanted to be involved in the industry
more than anything i wanted to be
involved in fitness because it changed
my life it was the thing that got me
from being a d student to an a student
literally that was the thing that
changed my life the discipline yeah the
discipline that i learned the structure
the fact that if i was tired on a monday
the gym doesn't care go in and lift it
doesn't matter and most importantly that
if january 1 i joined the gym and i left
five days a week every single week by
december 25 whatever i am better than i
was a year ago that that those lessons
to me were massive because previously i
didn't really realize that and i do this
thing in school where i would be like
i'd work try really hard and i get a bad
grade and then there'd be another thing
that i wouldn't try out and i'd get a
really good grade and i just it didn't
mean it didn't add up to me
so for me i was in love with the
industry and and fitness was and is my
passion and that carried me through some
of the difficult times because i
remember
the difference it's made to my life and
it's this inherent passion that drives
me every day
so if you've got no idea or money just
lean into that community whatever it is
it might be boxing it might be golf it
might be videography it might be
motorcycles or bicycles or whatever lean
into it because inevitably there will be
an opportunity
especially now because of this new
social media world that we live in
there's a massive there's so much room
for people to create brands so yeah i
would just lean into whatever your
passion is it's so true because look you
can waste a ton of time procrastinating
and falling into indecision by trying to
guess
and as you said there i read that
gymshark was actually like the seventh
apple website you created so you like
leaned into the industry did this
process of like failure and exploration
and stumbled across the winner right
like and you have to fail
one of the if you're a young
entrepreneur just do not be afraid to
fail just
all names out of boxes ideas out of
boxes aside the likelihood of an
individual starting a business and that
one being the one that strikes gold
is
ridiculously low what we've got to
remember is you could start 30
businesses and you are still more likely
to fail than you are succeed so just
honestly just keep trying and keep
trying and don't be afraid to fail i
think that's so so so important and
everyone i've met by the way from the
people that run businesses that are 10
times bigger than jim shark to every
entrepreneur that i've met every
business person every successful person
in sport in business whatever where
they've started a business or not every
single one of them has failed time and
time and time again and i think then
people look at the the final product and
just assume that they've just they were
either this incredible human who had was
born this way or and it is just never
never ever the case more often than not
the all the most successful people i've
ever met are all winging it they're all
literally just working incredibly hard
and they're just giving it their best
shot
i'm gonna ask you one more on this point
i think that was a superb answer as well
because it's just incredibly true i am
the other question i would i'd get a lot
from your entrepreneurs is something
like you know they're in a job at the
moment
and they've got an idea so this is an
example where they've got a business
idea that they want to pursue
um
but they're just you know they've heard
you say that they want to pursue it but
there's something holding them back
and they're you know i know you get this
a lot as well yeah
probably most conversations what you say
to those people
well i think if if it's your passion
then i think you should jump in the the
other thing i would say and this is i
think this is this is a dangerous thing
i do see people online in
quit your job jump in go and do
something and it's a bit like personally
i'm thinking no don't don't quit your
job it's fine like
like
i i i worked at pizza hut for whatever i
can't remember what the amount was it
was four or five pounds an hour
and jim sharp was doing hundreds of
thousands in revenue
the utility of having a job whilst
running the business is huge
one because you can earn money to
survive so you don't need to remove but
you know you don't need to remove money
from the business so two you can then
reinvest all the profits that you can
make in that business if you just and
two by the way if business number one
fails you've still got your job you try
number two number three number four and
i think
whatever it is find your passion
i genuinely don't think it's a good idea
just to jump out of your job just on a
whim
there are some people you'll hear about
the one in a million that succeeds and
congratulations more power to you i'm
super happy for those people but you
don't hear about the
99 that ended up quitting their job and
it didn't go as well as what they would
like and then they ended up having to go
back and find a new job so use that job
as a superpower as stability and invest
the money you earn from that job in the
business and just keep trying try and
try them and hard work where does that
feel
what's the importance of it because
there's a there's a narrative i talk
about this podcast that hard work is
maybe a little bit
the narrative you see online from like
the hustle porn stars a little bit toxic
yeah but
would you be sat here without hard work
oh definitely not no it's that
combination of
hard work alone is definitely not enough
you have to work hard but you also have
to work smart there were periods where
we were finding out ways to manipulate
google in a way that got gym chart to
the top which gave us huge revenue for
next to no cost right that was smart
work but there were days when we would
work 12 14 16 hours sewing and printing
t-shirts every single day
there are days like that now where i
just we just work and work and work to
get the job done so exclusively hard
work
won't solve your problems you definitely
have to work smart
but i've never met anyone
who was genuinely successful that wasn't
hard working
we have a new tradition
on the diary of a ceo i've heard about
this oh yeah okay they told you okay so
um the previous guest
writes a question for the next guest and
this is the first time i've seen the
question
i don't know if people believe when i
say that but um
their question to you is
what is the greatest gift
that another human has given you
oh
that's intense yeah i didn't see that
coming what is the greatest gift that
another human has given you
i'd have to i'd really have to think
about that the first thing that comes to
mind would be time
because i really so there's so many
people that have given genuine time to
me to like teach me take me under their
wing robin time to support me
emotionally my parents time to you know
teach me and bring me up grandparents
the people that i work with every day
um
so yeah it would definitely be something
around
time i love that
and it speaks to
i think your understanding of the
importance of time as well and i think
being a ceo you quickly learn oh yeah
very quickly you learn that time is
a finite resource and um
every second is planned i'm really
careful about how i spend my time and i
want to spend it the most effective and
productive way i possibly can yeah well
thank you for giving me your time today
because you know you're one of the
you're really you're a real anomaly as i
said at the start of this conversation
in the uk for so many reasons i mean the
business you've built as an anomaly as
you've described like
to have a brand like that that's reached
such scale
from the uk from a from a guy that was
20 and you're still in your 20s now
right um is just i mean
there's not another example in the uk
right it's just it's staggering and
i think you've done this tremendous
service in
doing the public speaking training you
did and really putting yourself out
there because now everybody gets to see
this this person and also you're one of
the most relatable people i've ever met
in every way um which means that you're
just by doing conversations like this by
putting yourself out there you're
empowering 18 year old steve bartlett's
or the future you know ben francis to
to that they can too and
when it's relatable and when you're a
guy like you are and when you're so like
i wouldn't say self-defecating but more
like when you're so humble
it just feels like um whatever position
the listener is in on this podcast they
they have a way out of that potentially
unpleasant situation so thank you so
much because it's uh honored to have you
back on and to observe your growth over
the years it's been super inspiring for
me thank you very much thank you
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast me and my team use that as an
indication of whether the episode is
good or not based on how many new
followers and subscribers we get thank
you so much
[Music]